hey youtubers is Charlie it's as we've
all probably had a few minutes to
process the Jesse Eisenberg
Lex Luthor news, I thought it was time to
talk about the Top 5 reasons why this
is going to be a good thing.
And do breakdown of what it might mean for
the story. SO many big things going down
this week. First Peter Capaldi gets
the new suit, now Mark Zuckerberg is Lex
Luthor.
There's even a bunch of Super Bowl Trailers
coming on Sunday. I'm actually be doing
videos for most them. Be sure to SUBSCRIE
to get all that stuff too!
So much comic book stuff happening right
now. Whether you love or hate the idea of Jesse
Eisenberg is not going to be a main
character in this, so don't freak out too
soon.
The Real Big players are going to be Ben
Affleck and Henry Cavill. They'll be the
main characters. They're going to be each
other's villains in the movie.
Lex Luthor is going to be a background
player. So let's get going, here's the Top
5 reasons why he's actually good
choice for the character:
Number 5: he's actually the right age
based on DC Comics Canon.
Lex Luthor and Superman are almost the
same age in the current version the
comic book story.
Jesse Eisenberg and Henry Cavill were
born in the same year. Obviously all those
push-ups make Cavill look just a
little bit older.
Number 4: This will be a background
role only. Lex Luther is not going to be
the main villain in this movie.
The main villain, if you consider it to
Superman movie, is going to be Batman.
If you consider it a Batman movie,
Superman is going to be the main villain.
For minor characters, unconventional
casting choices lead to much more
interesting stories.
Just look at Kat Dennings in Thor the
Dark World. She's a very minor character,
but she was one of the most, non-Loki enjoyable parts that movie.
I mean, even Wonder Woman is a minor
character in this film. it's really Henry
Cavill and Ben Affleck that are going to take the lead. They're going to eat most
of the screen time.
Number 3: he works really well in an
ensemble cast.
The Social Network which he's
most known for, was largely an ensemble
film, the way it was shot.
Andrew Garfield was just as big a star, if
not bigger now.
And later Eisenberg was actually able to
hold his own on screen against a post-
Avengers Mark Ruffalo. Yes Ben Affleck is
a much bigger A-lister than anyone he
starred with before.
But this all works in the character's
favor. Like I said, Lex Luthor's is
supposed to be a shadow player in this movie. Although he will probably get
Something of an origin story.
Number 2: he has the dramatic
background to play a much darker version
of the character than we've seen before.
Gene Hackman and Kevin Spacey were both
amazing actors in the role.
But their versions were much more
cartoony. Zack Snyder has given Superman
a much more serious tone, which demands a
much darker villain.
When I say dark I mean dark without
going to crazy Nicolas Cage
Ghost Rider territory. Bonus shout out for
the time that Nicholas Cage
almost became Superman. And my number one reason why he's a good choice for Lex
Luthor.
Mark Zuckerberg is the modern Lex Luthor.
In all the previous Superman stories
Lex Luthor was an Industrialist.
But we're living in the Information Age.
And Lex Luthor is supposed to be this
brilliant, if not
misguided Billionaire with a really
cold personality, which sounds just like
Mark Zuckerberg.
Not implying that Mark Zuckerberg is evil.
This is obviously a comic book villain we're
talking about.
Let me know whether not you come down on
the positive or negative side of
Jesse Eisenberg as Lex Luthor.
I'm actually really interesting to see
what he's going to look like in the
movie. Hopefully there will be some
images of the character soon. Obviously
we know Henry Cavill'd probably going to look like.
That Superman SuitI wont change a lot.
But we haven't seen any pictures of Ben
Affleck yet.
And obviously we haven't seen Wonder Woman yet either. Here's a breakdown of what the
casting might mean for the story of the
movie as well as the origins Lex Luthor
character and the origins of his
relationship with the Superman character.
Let's start with the Lex Luthor origin.
He'll be a tech leader so his rise to
power will be just like Mark
Zuckerberg's.
He'll have invented some tech and then had a shady reputation for cutting out business
partners and rivals along the way,
until eventually becomes this big
Billionaire. Now on to his relationship with
Superman.
Although they're roughly the same age, I
don't think that Lex Luthor and
Superman will have the same shared past
they did during Smallville
or previous versions the comic book.
Don't be surprised if Clark and Lois
end up doing a profile Luthor for The
Planet.
So Superman will probably meet Luthor
for the first time as Clark Kent,
not at Superman. I predict much the
opposite for his first meeting with
Batman.
I think they'll be meeting for the first
time as superheroes. Here's some of the best
rumors that I've seen so far, but careful
for potential spoilers for Justice
League plot lines and future movies.
So the best rumor I've seen says that during
the movie Lex Luthor will buy the Daily
Planet
as a PR move and Batman will end up
setting up the Justice League as a
Marvel S.H.I.E.L.D.-like answer to Superman's destruction a Metropolis in the
1st film.
Consider it an alternate reality
origin of The League.
But the rumor goes on to state that by
the end the movie, Superman will be
forced into exile by Batman
and the newly formed League. and the movie
will end before that is resolved.
Leaving any sequel or Justice League
movie, which ever comes next,
to bring Superman in to The League formally.
It's  just a rumor but it's the best one
I've seen so far.
Remember Superman and Batman are going
to go head to head in this movie, so they
will not be best buds.
Here's an interesting question.
Regardless of what the plot ends up being.
Do you think the next movie after this
will be a stand-alone Batman film for
Ben Affleck,
or will it be that Justice League movie?
In reality, it just depends on how much
money the movie makes.
Okay! So heads up, like I said this Sunday a
whole bunch of new movie trailers are coming
including
X-Men and Captain America. I'm going to be doing videos for all those. So be sure to
SUBSCRIBE to get everything.
I'll trry to post all those on the same night. Right now you can click here for a run down on
what all those trailers are going to be,
and click here to get this week's
episode of Arrow. They just introduce the
Red Arrow and Oliver spent a whole bunch of time training him. It was crazy.
Thank You so much for watching! I'll see you guys tonight, High Fives!